I found at a very early age that most of
the partisanship
in American politics was nonsense
and
and I've always felt that way I
certainly
I was
at the very most I was a Democrat
at the height of my
partisan politics I was a Democrat or a
liberal
but I wasn't really
and would never have voted a straight
party ticket
and so when I started
in my career talking about this stuff I
would always say that I was not
a liberal
that I was a Libo conservo
Rado
middle of the road
just like most of you you just haven't
given it enough thought lately
and and I hold to that to this day
and I think that most
by reducing our politics
to This Bitter and an ignorant
partisanship we do ourselves vast
disservices
and we should know better
I'm Dave Rubin and joining me today is
an academy award-winning actor author of
one thought scares me we teach our
children what we wish them to know we
don't teach our children what we don't
wish them to know
and a guy with a lot of moxie Richard
Dreyfuss welcome to the Reuben report
hiya
Richard you do have a lot of moxie for
some reason that line seemed like the
one that I should go to in the intro I
could have gone through about 800 movies
how do you feel about a lost in Yonkers
reference right up top
[Music]
um
for some reason every bio of me starts
out with what a cocky arrogant
guy I am or was or something and uh
I don't really I don't agree with it but
I don't you know want to start a war
so uh I let it go but
I think it's just that I'm
I tell my truth I tell the truth
I tell my truth whether it's Auntie
Richard or pro-richard
so
um
[Music]
surprised by that there was an article
once about the fact that Barbra
Streisand and Richard Dreyfuss were the
only two Jews who talked about being
Jews and loved it and
you know didn't expect any bad stuff to
come for that and I
and I know her and we talked about it
and it never occurred to me not to talk
about being Jewish I was proud of it
and so
but it's the kind of thing that was
covered by a lot of
fear or a lot of
not being candid
mm-hmm you know there were lots of the
actors in the earlier years who were
Jewish who wouldn't admit it
which I think is kind of silly
so we could go in all ways to start but
why don't we do a little a little bio
first uh because everybody knows uh you
from obviously jaws and close encounters
and what about Bob etc etc but can you
give me a little bit of a bio because
that'll kind of connect us to the book
because you have a sort of interesting
childhood related to politics in terms
of where you're at now
yeah
um I was
I was born in Brooklyn to a very
activist family my great aunt
assassinated Tsar Alexander in 1881.
an act which I'm very proud of
and uh
and my grandmother
[Music]
was a witness to the Triangle Shirtwaist
Factory Fire
and
walked away from that
catastrophe
and went directly to the Socialist Party
headquarters and volunteered and
eventually became Eugene Debs private
secretary
and
um
I
have always been their child
and my mother's child and uh
I once asked my mom
why were you a socialist and not a
communist
and she said better Donuts
is that a fact
that's a fact that's a fact and we lived
in Queens in an area in Queens which was
completely left-wing completely
socialist and communist and uh
the guy who was the head of the
Communist party on Long Island
was a big fat
hospital administrator named David and
he used to tell me stories about
what it was like to you know be a part
of the American Communist party and most
of the stories
um built in um
house silly and stupid they were
and he's talking as a present-day
communist
he thought they were just
that his group was particularly silly
and uh and he was always telling me
these stories because this is what
America was so frightened of
and
there was my father was asked uh my
father was not
a partisan
and he
he was asked
to run for the Board of Education in
Queens
we had crosses burned on our lawn
and blah blah
and so David called an executive cell
meeting
and all the top Communists in Long
Island met at his apartment
and they went downstairs to the basement
and David said okay we're here to
try to convince Norman Dreyfus to to run
for the board of education but it can't
be a communist movement it can't be
anything you know identified with us so
what do you think how should we do this
and one guy said well I think we should
do this and another guy said we should
do that and then another guy said well
speaking as a non-communist I'd like to
and everyone went
they just let him in because he was
their pal Stanley and Stanley walked
downstairs with them and he said that
was the the thing that everyone was so
afraid of in the early 50s
so
um
and also something that I don't think my
father really understood
because
my father was the head of a Jewish gang
in Brooklyn
in the 30s and every time his father
would close the candy store and move a
few blocks and reopen it
he had to fight his gang had to fight
the Irish and the Italian gangs
and and these were bloody fights and
these were sometimes to the death
like ripping out uh
antennas from cars and sticking them in
people's eyes and this was Pete prior to
the war
and then he went to the war
with his enemies
and he when they came back and he had a
violent War
and very dramatic
but when he came back he came back
not with enemies but with Brothers guys
who'd been through this experience with
him
and
and uh
I don't think that he realized that his
former enemies were now his best friends
and Neighbors
and I remember talking to one of his
friends who was Italian
and I said I get it I get it you're a
totalitarian psychopath is better than
his totalitarian exactly exactly
yeah and and that's
and I laughed myself sick and so did he
and he he laughed so much that his milk
spilled up through his nose
so
I found at a very early age that most of
the partisanship
uh in American politics was nonsense
and
and I've always felt that way I
certainly
I was
at the very most I was a Democrat
at the the height of my
partisan politics I was a Democrat or a
liberal
but I wasn't really
and would never have voted a straight
party ticket
and so when I started in my career
talking about this stuff I would always
say that I was not
a liberal
that I was a Libo conservo
Rado
middle of the Roto
just like most of you you just haven't
given it enough thought lately
and and I hold to that to this day
and I think that most
by reducing our politics
to This Bitter and an ignorant
partisanship
do ourselves vast disservices
we should know better and and nowadays
Republicans or or conservatives
can't wait to bring up
the word liberal as a curse word
and vice versa
Democrats do the same thing with
conservatives and the fact is
none of us are a straight Ticket Country
we don't do things like that
and we should know more one of the
simple reasons for knowing civics
is that you know from the get-go from
the beginning
opposing views are meant to be cherished
and if you don't
you are missing out on something that is
a remarkable
strength to our system if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
mindless dribble check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell